I hope you had a good day of workshops
yesterday and if not I hope you're gonna
have a good day today with the
conference but let's just right jump
into it shall we
this talk is about how to use git
effectively or rather how effective
teams use git my name is Enrico
Campidoglio I'm a freelance programmer
this is me freelancing from home these
days I also do a fair bit of training
and workshops and stuff like that and
these days I also do that from home who
would have thought anyway we're not here
to talk about that we are here to talk
about git now they it's never been a
better time to learn it these days there
are plenty of resources out there you
have books videos you have online
tutorials you have even podcasts about
git so with all these resources I mean
getting off the ground is not a problem
but while everyone including me is busy
telling is busy telling you how it works
nobody is giving you any advice on what
to do with it so that's the problem you
might wonder ok what do you mean by that
what I mean that if you know how
something works it doesn't really
doesn't mean that you necessarily know
how to use it in practice for example
it's like learning how to play the notes
on a piano but then you cannot play a
song so what you need is guidance but
wait a minute you say who will need
guidance using a source control system I
mean it's pretty self-explanatory right
and you would be right it has been that
way with traditional source control
systems like for example CBS perforce
you know subversion even TFS those
source control systems by
virtue of how they were designed they
were pretty much telling you how they
wanted to be used and there was no other
way get however is different because git
doesn't really have an opinion about
what you do with it I mean it is just a
content rocker it says it to writing the
manual write a stupid content tracker
it tracks the content of your files and
that's it what you how you use it in a
country in the context of software
development that's completely up to you
so instead of gift telling you how he
wants to be used it's more like you know
whatever whatever works for you I'm just
a Content trucker so yeah we need some
guidance but where do you find this
guidance well the hell we have the
second problem that I mean everybody use
git in a different way depending on your
project depending on the size of your
team what kind of software you're
building those are all things that
affect the way you use your big it and
you know how you do version control so
in order to learn how to use git
effectively what you can do is observe
how others use it and you know learn
from their experience see what works see
what doesn't work and you know write
things down and apply to your own so
that's what I have done so what is this
talk about this talk is about it's a
collection of you could call them habits
ideas things to think about that are
coming from people who use get in to
improve their workflow people who are
really good at being productive using it
and they do it both individually as well
as a team so you can see that you can
think of this talk as a collection of
things that you can now bring in into
your own experience and see how they
apply
to your workflow and to your project so
let's get started I had said that this
dis advices and this ideas that I'm
gonna share with you today they apply
both individually as well as in a group
because git being a distributed source
control system every repository is equal
so there are things you can do on your
own machine these I call personal
workflows and then there are the things
that you do with the rest of your team
and those I call teamwork flows so the
content all today I divide it into these
two categories just you know to keep
them clear and to be more specific I
give you three pieces of advice for
personal workflows and then three more
for teamwork flows all right sounds good
I hope it sounds good because I can see
none of you so I'm just gonna take that
as a yes
so let's start with the personal
workflows let me just jump right over to
the demo so what you're seeing here is a
command line oh by the way I forgot to
mention that this the things I'll show
you today I'm gonna use get from the
command line to demonstrate these things
however most of what I'm going to show
you applies just as well if you're using
it from a through a GUI to a graphical
user interface and if it's something
that just applies to the cursor to the
command line I'm gonna tell you alright
first thing first advice that comes from
teams that use git effectively on
personal workflows is to get comfortable
now did actually means configure
environment you know git is a rather
complex tool to say the least so there
is no need to make it any more
uncomfortable to use than it already is
and there are many options and
configuration settings you can apply to
your environment to make it a more place
tool to use the first I want to share to
share with you is and this applies to
the command line is to install a get
aware prompt so what is that it's what
you're seeing right here if you're
sitting in a command line
there are utilities you can install that
will enrich your prompt with information
that comes from a git repository for
example you will see the branch alone
and as we're gonna work with our files
this plant will show us the number of
modified files you know stuff like that
so what kind of prompt are there out
there so if you are using Windows and
PowerShell I recommend you install
Porsche get and if you are Linux or if
you are using the windows subsystem for
Linux and you prefer or you are using
for example cygwin windows if you're
using bash
I recommend the bash get prompt if
instead you are looking for something
cross-platform
I highly recommend and this is my
favorite something called starship and
that it's it's the one you're seeing
right here starship is a cross-platform
con console prompt get aware which is
also written in rust so extra bonus for
coolness factor the other thing I want
to share with you is how to get pretty
deep in your plant so you're gonna be
looking at a lot and this also applies
just to come to the command line you're
gonna be looking at a lot of disk if
you're working with git and you know the
diff format everybody knows how it looks
like can sometimes be hard to read
so there are you there is a utility you
can install that prettify z-- your diffs
in the console and that is called diff
so fancy this comes on an MP on ma NPM
module so you say NPM install diff so
fancy which already deal
and once you have it installed you need
to tell get to pipe all the diff
information through deep so fancy before
it gets printed on to the console and
you do that through a configuration
setting called pager so you say git
config core dot pager and you basically
set it to diff so fancy and then you
pipe it to less to print it onto the
screen and once you've done that you can
basically say for example you can say
diff the committee that's in head that's
referenced by head compared it with the
one before head and you get something
like this so you see first let me show
you how it looks like if you skip the
pager you tailgate you know don't pipe
the deep information to the pager this
is how a normal regular diff looks like
and once you have this so fancy it looks
like this so you see all the plus and
minuses are removed and it even
highlights exactly what in the file in
the string has changed plus it gives you
this really nice header up here so div
so fancy good stuff the next one has to
do with whitespace handling now as
programmers you know that whitespace
matters and it matters a lot and
especially you need to be consistent
with your words white space usage well
it turns out that git has built-in
features to help you keep your
whitespace consistent throughout your
files what you need to do is tell git
what invalid whitespace and you do that
through an option called
called white space so in
in this case I said that I don't want
any blank I don't want any like white
space at the end of a line I don't want
any white space at the end of a file and
the regarding indentation I don't want
to see any tabs in annotation instead I
want to see spaces like it should be
right so you are telling you to wall
what you should consider
invalid white space and after you have
done that you can use git diff with the
check option to check for invalid white
space so let me give you an example
let's open up so this is just a
consultant core console application let
me show you real quick how it looks like
I have a CS prod file and a command line
program written in C sharp pretty simple
stuff so let's open up the source code
and let's make a change right here let's
for example do like this and then on
this line right here let's add a bunch
of in Y space at the end of a line so
you see by the way that starship has
updated my view I have a modified file
there you go and so let's go let's do
git diff check and you see that git is
showing me I have invalid white space
exactly here at the end of the line so
that's pretty cool however you know you
need to remember to invoke it which you
know that doesn't always have to be the
case so if you're gonna be effective
with kit you need to I was gonna see
later automate as much as possible
so let's say that I want to go ahead and
I forgot to check for the whitespace and
I'm just gonna commit the file and add
some invalid whitespace what happens if
I happen to commit some value by space
well no worries because you can use the
rebase command with the whitespace
option equals to fix and get will go
through the commit included in the
rebase and automatically fix any
whitespace errors for you according to
these rules so let's let's let's take a
look at our latest commit you see that I
have the invalid whitespace here and now
let's do a rebase let's start it from
the root of the repository just to be
sure and I'm gonna say whitespace equal
fix oh sorry
git rebase let's start to commit ago and
then say white space equal fix so you
see that I've the last two comets have
been re-evaluated and let's take a look
at our and the white space is gone so
pretty cool stuff to be effective to use
the git features to be effective the
next one is conflict handling no it's a
fact of life that we're gonna have merge
conflicts especially we get to being a
distributed source control systems where
everybody is working as synchronously
from each other so git has some no
topknots features to handle conflicts
one of them is something called
three-way merge now let's let me get rid
of the
artifacts over here so I have a bronze
cold feature let let me just highlight
it for you have a branch cool feature
that I want to merge into master and
there is a conflict in the commit refers
by feature so let's see how a normal a
conflict resolution looks like you say
git merge feature and you see here that
I have a conflict in the program dot C S
now if you take a look at what I have in
my working directory you see that you
know get is gonna enter the so called
merge conflict headers what is telling
me okay this is where this is how the la
the conflicting lines look like in the
Committee that you are merging into and
this is how they look like in the
community that you're merging and you
see that one commit let me see if I can
highlight it here one commit is adding a
comma but keeping the exclamation mark
and the other one doesn't have the comma
and doesn't even have the exclamation
mark so what is it gonna be now if
you're gonna reserve a conflict it's
useful to see here but how did it look
like before either of those commits in
other words how did these lines look
like in the commit that's the common
parent of the conflicting quits and
that's where the three-way merge comes
in because three-way merge means you're
not only comparing two sides of a merge
conflict you're comparing two sides
against each other and against their
common parent three-way merge now you
can tell git that you are you want to do
a three-way merge by setting the
conflict style option to diff three
words three stands for three-way merge
so let's do that
let's first abort this this merge and
now we are gonna say git config conflict
merge conflict style d3 and now let's do
the merge again still getting the
conflict of course let's see how this
looks like now and you see that now I
have an extra set of lines right over
here and this is how the lines look like
in the common parent so now I have a
better you see before it had the
exclamation mark this line removes the
exclamation mark and this line this line
here at the comma so now I have a much
better context to resolve the conflict
which makes me more effective so that's
it for merge conflicts let's move on to
global ignores now you might have
noticed before that if I open up the
file now this is vim but I have
installed only sharp which is basically
giving you intelligence inside of him
and all the redditors and after a while
if you see if I and edit this file after
a while I'm gonna get like see ended
here we go you see that I'm getting
warnings and I'm getting compiler errors
I bet nobody spotted that one before so
this means that my code has been
compiled in the background so if I exit
this file now
I have you see over here i have an
untracked file and what file is that you
might wonder well it's D object the
directory the object and beam have
appeared because the Omni sharp has
compiled my code in the background and I
have no get ignore so that's why those
appear are as untracked now if you're
gonna work with the same kind of
language and the same kind of technology
stack that means that you're gonna have
the same kind of files and directories
that you want to ignore in all of your
projects for example if you're working
with that you're always gonna want to
ignore the object and the bin
directories because in those directories
you have the binaries now rather than
having the same content everywhere in
all of your get ignores you can have a
global get ignore that applies to all
the repositories on your local machine
and so you what what it what it is it's
basically a git ignore that you put in
your home directory and then you tell
get to use that as the global ignore
file by setting the core exclude file
option which have here excludes file so
you see that's my home directory so what
we can do in this case is that we can
open up the global get ignore and right
now it just contains everything that
starts with tilde and this directory and
we're just gonna add bin and herbs to
the list of the global ignores and you
see that immediately without doing
anything before
it used to be untracked and now it's
gone
and as you can see I still don't have
any get ignore in my directory so it's
already ignoring being a knobbed so very
useful if you're using if you're working
which is not likely they're gonna did
you work with the same kind of language
and the same kind of frameworks to have
a global ignore on your machine the last
one of the get comfortable set of
options
is always push new tags now you might be
surprised to know that when you create a
tag which you probably do when you want
to release a version of your software is
that new tags don't automatically get
pushed where regular get push operation
if you want your tags to come along with
the push you need to pass the follow
tags option now a chance that you're
going to forget to do that are very high
so by setting the push dot follow tags
option to true new tags are always going
to automatically be pushed for you
switching gears there you go the second
group of advice that I want to give you
when it comes to personal workflows in
order to be more efficient is to craft
your history and what do I mean by that
I mean that you need to create
committees that are readable and that
make your history easy to follow for the
future generations and for a future
future of course now how do you create
good commits you might wonder well good
commits have a set of properties that I
call acid so I'm gonna go through this
what what acid commits are and by the
end of it you're gonna have a pretty
good idea of how to craft your commits
so that they make your history easy to
read
and easy to follow so the a in acid
stands for autonomous good commits
should make one logical change that is
independent from other commits that
means that commits should be cohesive
not only should he make one change but
all the changes inside a commit should
be related to each other now how do you
use git to make autonomous commit to my
wonder you use something called a paths
commit now let me show you what I mean
let's open up our file again and you see
that right now let's say that I want to
make two changes I want to for example
fix this bug that we saw before and also
I want to you see over here this is
telling me that this using statement is
unused so you do a clean up I remove
this line and I then also want to fix
the bug so now if I do a git if now I
made two changes I made one change that
affects the functionality on your
software that you know didn't compile
before but after this committee is going
to compile and then I also made a clean
up that doesn't really affect the
functionality of the code now these are
two different changes two different
kinds of changes and they should be into
two different commits but however I made
them into the same file so how can i
split my changes into different commits
that's where the paths commit option
comes in so what you do instead of
saying git add and then your file like
you will normally do you add the - -
patch or - B option
and what happens is that get is gonna
see what changes you made and ask you
for each of them do you what well it's
not it's not really asking you anything
right because git is cryptic but what
this means is do you want to stage the
sank that means do you want to add this
change to your next commit and then you
have these options over here so you
might guess that Y means yes so do you
want to add this yes what about the
other one by the way I also have white
spacer
so yeah let's keep it for the time being
so do you want to add this one I say no
and what I have now is that I have a
split I have a split situation the same
file is partially committed and
partially still Solly is partially added
to the stage area and partially still in
my working directory how do you find out
what's in the staging area you say DIF
cache you see what I'm about to commit
is just the cleanup and what I have in
my working directory is the change that
I made the functionality so now I can
just say git commit and I say removes
unused using and then I can just say
commit all fixes the compiler error so
now I split the two changes into two
different commits using the patch patch
patch commit the C stands for correct
good commit should not break the state
of your project they're kind of
intuitive but by having committed that
you know are correct allows you you know
to pick and choose commit from different
branches and apply them to your own
branch without being worried that you're
gonna break
after now how do you how do you do how
do you ensure that the water about to
change that what about to come it
doesn't break the software well you have
two options the first one is to use safe
keep index so let me just undo what I
just did now the last two commits and
let's try it again so let's open up this
file now I'm and just me just gonna do
remove this and then I'm gonna make the
same change over here now I have these
two two changes again and the let's
again add the let's just add the first
one so we say add P program do you want
to commit this yes don't commit this no
now what you want to do is that you want
to compile run your tests do everything
that's necessary to ensure that the
change you made doesn't break your
software however you just want to
include what's in the index in the
staging area you don't want to include
any other changes that are not about to
be committed so how do you do that you
basically stash away everything that's
not in the index and keep what's in the
index in the index so you say geese -
save keep index then I say fixes the
compiler error and what
right now is that you see this change is
no longer in my working directory it's
gone what I have is I just have what I'm
about to commit so now I can say dotnet
build for example order not run the
tests and everything to make sure that
what I did doesn't break the software oh
there it is of course is there error
from before so yeah actually let's do
the other one but you get the point
let's do the no let's do the other
change let's do this
and that do this so I should have
committed to the other one so let's make
these two changes we go line so let me
just do deep patch commit again well you
say do you want to commit this no this
time yes this time now I have this split
situation and I just want to check that
the error that I corrected works so
let's toss stash save the message
now I'm gonna stash away the removes the
unused using and keep the index perfect
now let me see what
I have staged I have just the fixed
arrow over here and now I can verify
that what I have about to commit indeed
fixes the problem and it does so I can
safely commit it fixes the compiler
error and then I want to get back what I
stashed away so I say get stash pop and
now I get back the file that I had
before and I can continue working moving
on how if you have a list of commits
like this how do you make sure that what
you have every commit by itself doesn't
break the software well what you can do
in that case is that you can again use
the V base with the - - exact option and
what I will do is that that way let me
just show you let's start a rebase from
the beginning of the the history in this
case and you say that for each of those
commits you want to run a command what
command you want to run you want to run
the dotnet build for example and let's
just make it interactive so I can show
you what it does you see that for each
of the commits get is going to add the
command you've specified after each one
so what what happens is that for each
individual commit it is going to try in
this case to compile and see that the
does this come in to break anything and
if it does is gonna stop and give you
the chance to fix it so let's just save
this file and you see it goes back to
the his in the history runs the command
for the first one then runs the command
for the second one and here it breaks
because this is is the commit that
introduced the error so this at least
this point you see that indeed this is
where the
the problem started so you can fix it
and then continue the rebase so this is
a really good way to make sure that each
individual commit doesn't break the
history of your sword or doesn't break
the state of your software the I in acid
what does it mean means incremental now
if you have if working on a branch with
a bunch of commits you want to make sure
that the order of those commits is a
logical progression of your work in that
branch so that it makes sense
what kind of changes you made and your
thought process during those changes now
what how do you do that well you already
saw it right now you make an interactive
rebase so for example let's say that I
am I want to make sure that the order of
the commits that I have in my branch
reflects my my design process my thought
process I say interactive in this case
I'm going to start from the beginning
and once I have this list of commits
that are in my brain in my branch I can
for example you know reorder them
I can squash commit in to each other so
that they become one if I have a bunch
of temporary commits in this case I have
this committee over here that fix is a
compiler error that was actually
introduced over here so I don't know if
I haven't shared those commits yet I
haven't pushed them I have a I have the
chance to fix this history so that this
one appears in the right order or rather
it's included into that one so what you
can do is that you take this one and you
move it right below the committee want
to squash it into
then you change the option to from pick
to fix up and what this will do is that
the gate will basically take this commit
and include it into that one then you
save and hopefully you don't get a merge
conflict during the process that's
because I've changed the other one the
deadline before anyway one should well
let no I don't have time to fix this
merge conflict once you reorder your
commit they will make more sense for
everybody as to to look at D D the last
one stands for documented and what this
means is that a commit should clearly
state the state serving school should
clearly state the change that it made
and provide as much information as
possible about the context in which the
change was made and of course that's the
commit message that you that you specify
now the third category of tips that I
want to share with you about personal
workflows is to automate and you have
already seen a bit of it and automate
means let it do the work for you
basically now you know about aliases in
Inc it you can associate a in alias to a
command and over a command and a
combination of options for example I
have an alias that I use all the time
called LG and what this does is that it
runs git log and then it basically
beautifies my history by including only
certain information about a commit and
then coloring it with different colors
so when I say get algae I get a nice and
tidy history now you might be surprised
to know that you
can also associate shell functions to
aliases for example one that I picked up
years ago is one called undo so let me
show you how it looks like you say alias
dot undo in this case and you see I'm
basically defining a a function you can
call it anything
well first you say that is you start
your alias with a let me see there you
go Oh
wrong one you start your alias with an
exclamation mark which means that
whatever comes afterwards should be
evaluated as a shell function then I'm
defining a shell function called F could
be called anything and the body of the
function is a git command which is
accepting a parameter that I pass from
the command line and at the end of the
alias I just invoked a function so what
aliased functions allow me to do is they
allow me to the function function that
can take parameters and associate them
to get aliases so in this case the undo
it's gonna reset my the head reference
to a certain number of commits backwards
into in history so for example if I have
this and I want to undo the last one I
can say git undo 1 and now you see that
I have effectively removed remove this
commit and went back into the other one
so alias function are a quick way to be
really effective we get from the command
line get
also a lot of automatic features you
have seen that we can automatically push
new tags for example so I call this out
of this and out of that how to stash
what does it do if you have the files
that are modified in a word key
directory and you start a rebase it is
gonna stop you and say ah I can't rebase
because you have uncommitted changes
well what outer stars does is that
whatever you have in your working
directory it is going to automatically
stash away do the rebase and then
unstitch it afterwards for you and then
you have something called Auto squash
where this one I really want to show you
you saw before the squash operation that
we did where we move the one commit
underneath another one so you can also
do that quickly instead of doing
afterwards instead of doing the work
yourself let me show you how it works so
here actually let's get rid of this so
that hopefully we don't get a merge
conflict and then we also fix the
problem over here so now I'm gonna stage
the entire file now if I look at the
history I know that this what I'm about
to commit now I want to later squash it
into this one because that's the commit
that introduced the error so what I can
do is that instead of just making a
regular commit I'm gonna say commit fix
up and then I have to tell git okay
which commit are you going to squash
this into later well I want to squash it
into the commit whose message contains
the word executable and I'm using this
special syntax over here
to say squash it into a commit that
contains whatever whose message contains
the word that I'm specifying afterwards
so when I do that it is gonna commit my
changes and add the fix up exclamation
mark at the beginning of the commit
message and then the commit message of
the committed that's gonna be squashed
into later so what this means is that
when I do a rebase let me say git rebase
interactive you see that git has
automatically moved it to under the
right commit because it has matched the
commit message and it is really useful
if you want to fix a bunch of commits
that happened before you can just you
know commit away and use the option that
I showed you and then when you do a
rebase it is going to automatically move
the commits in the right spot all right
the last one of this is use client
client side hooks to automate a part of
your workflow so in every git repository
there is a directory called git and
underneath there is a technical hooks
and these are all shell scripts that are
gonna fire at certain points in the
history sorry
that they're gonna fight when certain
things happen in a repository for
example one commits one event that is
very interesting is the commit message
event this is gonna fire whenever you
are about to create a commit and at this
point you can have scripts that run at
certain point during the when you're
using it and for example the commit
message is interesting because you can
use it to evaluate the commit message
that you are about to to specify and to
make sure that it follows the convention
now in this case
I have a script defined there in commit
message that basically what it does is
that it evaluates the commit message and
makes sure that the first line is not
longer than 51 characters or 50
characters because that's how a
well-formed commit message should look
like and if it doesn't it's gonna give
me a warning and a chance to modify it
so let's try it out let's do let's just
do a an empty commit just to demonstrate
and I'm gonna say this commit message is
too long definitely longer than 50
characters and here I'm getting the the
event the commit message script as fired
and I'm getting the warning that says no
the first commit the first line in your
commit message should be 50 but it's 63
do you want to modify it or do you just
want to continue and this is a excellent
way to automate portions of your
workflow through scripting and that's
that's it for the personal workflows
let's move on to team workflows and I
have three tips for you here as well so
the first one is branching now I'm not
gonna give you advice on which of the
many kind of workflows you should use in
your project git flow github flow
you name it flow what instead I'm gonna
tell you is things you can think about
in your team when you are deciding and
when you are evaluating which kind of
flow you want to use and the rules for
evaluating workflows are very simple
be aware of the different kinds of
branches that exist now what do I mean
by that in guitar essentially two kinds
of branches you can create you can
create the long-running branches or you
can create topic branches now let's take
a let's take a look at an example a
long-running branch every repository has
at least one long-running branch and
that's of course master that's the
branch that exists for as long as the
project itself exists that's why it's
called long run and usually it contains
the work from multiple contributors if
instead you want to do some specialized
work for example let's say that you're
working on a feature that is a branch
that's gonna exist for a short period of
time and that usually contains the work
of one contributor and it's focused on a
species specific task that's why it's
called a topic branch topic branches
usually eventually get merged into the
long-running branch and then they
disappear so they are short-lived when I
told you that there are two categories
of branches it was not completely true
there are actually two more kinds of
branches you can create you can create
public branches and you can create
private branches now git is a
distributed source control system which
means that every repository is equal but
we all agree to have one copy one of
these repositories is deemed the the
canonical one and that's usually gonna
be hosted on a central server for
example github or Azure DevOps now a
branch that exists in a shared repo is
technically accessible by anyone but on
and instead the branches that exists on
your local repo that is on your local
machine they are all accessible by you
so a branch that's on a shared repo
after a sample master it's a public
branch and a branch that exists only on
your local machine for example you are
working on a feature just by yourself
that's a private branch so to put it all
together you have long-running branches
and long-running branches are usually
public by the same token topic branches
are usually private however this is what
usually happens but it's not the only
option you can have long-running rabid
branches for example you have an idea
you have an experiment you want to try
out however you don't want to share that
branch with anyone but you'll keep it
you keep it around for a long time that
is technically a private long-running
branch by the same token if you have
multiple people in your team working on
for example on a user story and that
user story is being worked on in a topic
branch a focused branch only on that
feature then you're gonna have any
public topic branch however not all
combinations are equally good long
running public branches those are okay
actually those are necessary in the case
of master topic branches that are
private are also okay however keeping a
long-running branch that although only
you have access to keeping it around for
a long time is a problem because the
longer you keep the branch around the
harder is gonna be to keep it in sync
with the main branch that's being shared
by the same token having topic branches
that are focused on solving a particular
problem and keeping them public that is
multiple people are gonna contribute to
that it's very easy to have people step
on each other's toes and you end up with
merge conflicts and stuff like that so
that's not a combination that you want
to have so that means that long-running
public branches
you should try to be conservative with
them don't have too many long-running
branches and don't have too many public
branches keep that number of branches
low on the other hand topic branches and
primes is that only you have
use them as much as possible because
that's what gift is about branching is
cheap and so you should use it to your
own advantage
now the other tip is about merging now
that you know that there are different
kinds of branches you should let the
kind of branches you want to merge you
should let them decide how they want to
be merged so you have to kind of merges
you have the exo called through merge
and you have the rebase through merge of
course is when an actual merge
committees being created to tie two
different lines of history and a rebase
is when you are changing the base of a
branch and then merging it to a phosphor
let me show you what I mean a public
branch that's gonna be merged into
another public branch in that case you
want to have a merge commit between them
because you want to make it really
visible when to public branches have
merged together if on one doll head you
have a public branch that you want to
merge into a private branch for example
you are working on a feature and you
want to bring in the latest commits from
master into your own feature branch in
that case you don't want to have a merge
commit because that merge commit is only
interesting to you nobody else is
interested in that since you are merging
into a private branch in that case you
want to do a rebase for example a public
app an example of this with a pull
request the get merged into master you
want that to appear as a merge commit or
if you are a merging master into your
own work-in-progress branch you want to
have that as a rebase why is that let's
say that you have a master branch like
this
that is public of course and then you
have a pull request that is also public
because it has to be cool reviewed and
you want to then merge the pull request
into master now the fact that you made
it as a merge commit one you later
delete the pull request branch because
that's been merged if it turns out that
there is a problem with that pull
request then it's easy because you can
just revert the merge commit and you
have automatically undo whatever came in
through that merge commit so in this
case having a visible merge commit makes
it easy to undo whatever was done in
that pull request branch with a single
in reverts reverted merge commit which
in this case is set as represented with
the W because W is the opposite of an M
if instead you had rebased
that is you have rebase your pull
request branch into master and that you
move master forward if you had done that
and then it turns out that there is a
problem you have to evaluate each commit
individually to find out which of them
introduced the problem and if there are
a bunch of them
that's gonna be a problematic to to find
and if must the master branch has moved
forward is going to be even trickier to
undo them by the same token when you
have a private branch that is a work in
progress and you want to keep it updated
with whatever happens in master if you
had done if you had done it through a
regular merge commit you have a public
and a private branch
then let's say that you have immersed
whatever came into master into your own
private topic branch to immerse commit
what happens then later when you want to
merge your topic branch into master
again and what happens is that you have
emerged commit then again because you're
merging private into public and you see
at this point you have a double merge
and if you do this enough your history
is gonna look like this and there is
actually a name for this kind of history
this is called the Guitar Hero history
why because if you look at it it reminds
a lot of how how the strings look like
in Guitar Hero or get hero so you don't
want to do that the third and final
thing to think about in your team in
your team workflows has to do with
releasing software so now that you know
that there are different kinds of
branches and now that you know the rules
for merging these kinds of branches now
the third thing to think about is map
these branches to your release
environments in other words know where
your branches are going what do I mean
by that so let's say again that I have
this master branch and then I have
another long-running branch which is
called develop now you want to map these
two branches to different environments
so for example the develop we're gonna
deploy whatever is in developed to a
test or a QA environment where it's
going to be verified whatever it is he
mastered however once we merge that work
into master we are going to put we're
gonna push that into production so that
it can be used by the customers
so these keeps you have nice way to map
to know what the changes that you are
making in a certain branch in what
environment are they going to be
deployed into and you can also do
different the promised strategies for
example in a develop branch where you're
deploying to a test or QA
you can do that on every commit
automatically and that will be like
that's called continuous deployment will
automatically continuous in deploying
your software to attest QA environment
for production you can do that for
production as well however since it's
riskier you maybe want to have that as a
an automatic process but that is
manually triggered in that case you want
to do continuous delivery that is
whatever is the master is always
deployable at any time however the
actual deployment process is triggered
through an explicit and intentional
action instead of having it
automatically so let's wrap this up with
the one minute to spare we talked about
how effective teams use git and how they
use them in two categories first when it
comes to personal workflows get
comfortable and configure get so that
it's a more pleasant tool to use may
take care of crafting your history by
following the rules of acid autonomous
correct incremental and documented so
that your history is readable and the
third one is use git feature to automate
as much as possible of your workflow so
that you have less work to do and it can
catch any errors that you that might
happen the second category of things to
think about has to do with teams team
workflows stuff that you do in
collaboration with others and this has
to do the first category of tips was be
aware of the kinds of branches that
there are and be aware of how they
should be merged together and those two
rules to those those two things if you
think about them they're gonna guide you
when you're evaluating different kinds
of workflows to use in your team the
third one is be aware of where the code
that's in every branch is going to end
up in and have a clear map
in between branches and your deployment
environments and with that I want to
just let you know that what I surely
today there is much more than than that
that you can do with git and I have a
precise course out that's called
advanced key tips and tricks where I
cover these things and much more so
there is the link over there and also I
want to remind you that in for the month
of April you can watch as much
Pluralsight as want as you want for free
so there is that and with that I want to
say thank you for watching and enjoy the
rest of the conference
you
hate me again I notice that there are a
couple of questions in a slider so if
you want to skip the break and just hang
hang around for the for the answer so
let me see so anonymous says without
squash and using the fix-up when
committing what if multiple commits
match the word you specify well in that
case what get will do is that it will
automatically move them underneath the
right commit but it's gonna wait wait I
misinterpreted what if multiple commits
match the words specified yeah in that
case it was gonna move it to the first
one it matches going backwards from from
the latest commit that you made that in
contains the fix up exclamation mark in
the in the message it is gonna match
backwards the first one it matches is
gonna move it underneath that one so the
next one is also anonymous any
recommendation on how to automatically
update the build version numbers in
projects before doing a commit yes I
have a recommendation there is a tool
that's up on github called git version
and what is get version does it ties
very well into the discussions I had
about different kinds of branches and
what what environment they're deployed
in to what get version does is that it
allows you to define rules that based on
the name of the branch are on and by
looking at how many commits have
happened in that branch since the last
tag for example it get version is gonna
automatically generate a version number
for you so for example let's say that
you are in the develop branch and you
run git version on the latest commit get
version is gonna generate a pre-release
version number following the rules of
cember because you are in the develop
branch and whatever
having developed is going to end up in
the QA so it's a preview by the same
token if you run git version on the
master branch
that's a production branch and then get
version is gonna generate another
preview but a stable version number so
git version is the one I recommend to
automatically generate semver version
numbers based on the kind of branch that
you are on yeah that's it thank you
thank you again for watching and I hope
you enjoy the rest of the day